[Music]
so
primarily what i'm interested in right
now is um
the 21st century is is particularly
perilous and uh we stand
at the precipice of human extinction and
a lot of this has to do
with i think
taking responsibility as individual
persons for
the kinds of beliefs that we have um you
know
as as technology becomes increasingly
powerful the
degree to which we require wisdom with
which to properly manage it uh
continues to increase um and
there's a lot of bad ideas and people
have a lot of trouble
with um like formulating
correct beliefs and knowing to use
rationality and
um like what is it that i should believe
and how do i know who the experts are
and uh this kind of thing so we have
this this big problem of information
um and what this has brought me to
is reflecting on
the strengths and weaknesses of western
scientific and rational traditions
as well as as wisdom traditions for
example
so i mentioned kind of this new the new
atheism of the
of the 2010s um which i think has its
own strengths and weaknesses
um as well as i think um
kinds of beliefs and attitudes you find
in science as well as beliefs and
attitudes you find in
in wisdom traditions so i kind of want
to do a tour with you
of say the last few thousand years of
epistemology and metaphysics and ethical
development to kind of comb through to
see the
strengths and weaknesses of each uh kind
of belief like
from from religion and mysticism to to
science and materialism and physicalism
to
to quantum mechanics and how they've all
kind of interacted and try to leech off
of each other in in certain ways
um so why don't we start here now
with um going back a few thousand years
to to perhaps the what you might see
as the the strengths and weaknesses of
something like
uh like religion or or mysticism
given that this is a predominant force
in in the world still today
well i think if we were 2000 years ago
uh it would have made perfect sense to
be
religious you know we didn't know enough
about the world if you just ask
uh what is the best explanation for the
world you see
we didn't have nearly the resources to
provide sensible alternatives to the
idea
that it was created by some force some
creature
some intelligence greater than our own
and we more importantly didn't quite yet
have
the epistemological tools to figure out
how to go about answering these
questions
uh we you know we certainly had uh
empiricism
as an idea aristotle was pretty much
empirical in many of the things that he
talked about
um but it wasn't entrenched as the right
or only way to go about
doing things and certainly you know
pythagoras
etc would have been more rationalist uh
in the old sense of rationalist the idea
that we can
just come up with true things about the
world by thinking about it carefully
without going out and looking at it
uh so i don't blame anyone who 20 2500
years ago or 2
000 years ago who thought the world was
enchanted and full of spirits and
and uh essences that were pushing things
around
but you know we made progress since then
yeah so there's so
i see this tension there between the
kind of wisdom developed in terms of uh
like experiential and and life wisdom
with the kind of failure
of modeling the world right so
the modeling of the world is is
increasingly spooky in that kind of
paradigm yet there are
for example bits of experiential wisdom
or or life wisdom which
um are still like valid today
um and so there's this there's this
there's this tension between the
epistemology of the inner and the outer
world
that that begins there that i view as
science
sort of rectifying the the failure of
that the
the modeling of the outer world uh as
time goes on
yeah i'm not sure if it's uh fair to
say they did better at one thing than
the other when you talk about uh
describing the world versus judging it
ethically or morally i mean i agree with
you
that there are ideas that were put
forward in ancient wisdom traditions
that we still find
wise and useful today but there are also
a lot of ideas we find
horrible and important today of course
and likewise for describing the world
um there were ideas put forward about
describing the world that we still find
useful today you know aristotle says
in order to keep something going you
have to keep pushing it right
and galileo and so forth even cena come
along and say well we don't
really need to do that there's
conservation of momentum but in the real
world in our everyday lives your car's
not going to go
unless you actually put the engine on
and actually provide some
propulsion so it was a model of the
world that wasn't wholly false
it was just wildly incomplete and
nowhere near able to
extend to the regimes that we're now
able to extend to with higher technology
better ways of looking at the world so i
would say that both
our ability to describe the world
scientifically and
our ability to think about ethics and
morals in the world
uh are not entirely disconnected from
ancient traditions but have improved
upon them in important ways
yeah i totally agree um yeah so
yeah the yeah the epistemology of the
inner and the outer world i think have
both
clearly increased since then um
certainly in terms of ethics
um so eventually we come to at least in
the west the the age of enlightenment
which features the promotion of reason
and the scientific revolution and
humanism which is
uh this this this moral progress that
we're beginning to talk about
um and and you know atheism
as that kind of become more became more
popular in the late 20th century
century and early 21st century is this
kind of humanism which is
born of enlightenment reasoning um
there's also philosophical progress
obviously um
and so here there seems to be
this this this this epistemological
valuing of of reason as primary
and sort of like language and
communication is the methodology by
which we
come to like moral truths and also
scientific truths
yeah you know i think that uh again
there's sort of fine distinctions to be
drawn here like if you again told
aristotle or plato uh that we need
reason to understand the world better
they would be like yeah sure
i don't disagree with that now i agree
that enlightenment thinkers
often portrayed themselves as champions
of reason but it wasn't
in opposition to sort of ancient greek
philosophy he was in opposition to
religious dogma
right yeah and you know if you tell if
you talk to the right religious people
they will also say oh yes we're all
about reason you know religion is is a
tough
thing because there are many people who
claim to be part of the same
religious traditions yet have very very
different ways of thinking about it
right
um so i even the whole thing is very
messy historically and i don't claim to
be an expert on it
what i'd like to emphasize is this
empirical aspect of
the enlightenment tradition in the
scientific revolution the
the fallibility of it i mean that's
really the key move
and uh it's it's kind of interesting and
ironic to me the fact that the major
move that made progress
uh epistemologically in the
enlightenment was a humble
move right to say well we can't just
think our way
true to the right answer we need to sort
of make guesses
make hypotheses and then go out there
and look at the world and we could be
wrong
whereas many of the people who are
actually doing this are very far away
from being humble
that remains true to this day personal
humility as far as i can tell does not
correlate with
intellectual humility when it comes to
understanding the world but
to me that was that was really the most
important thing the idea is that you
the idea that you can't just reach your
mind out there into the world and come
to
interesting conclusions about it that
are also correct
you can by all means you know come to
interesting conclusions about
logic and math and and pure reason but
the world and how it operates you need
to go and look at it
and that wasn't an easy tradition right
i mean plenty of people
from descartes to kant uh didn't quite
fit into that tradition even though we
think of them as part of the
enlightenment and the scientific way of
thinking
they were still quite convinced that
they could think their way
into how things worked so it's a tough
lesson
to learn i think yeah the the kind of a
priori
armchair reasoning of of descartes is
yeah quite successful and again you know
just just to be super duper fair here
there is always an element of that that
you can't
get rid of and then descartes actually
kind of even though
he ended up in a in a weird place he was
an important part of
teaching us that with you know basically
the first step of his move to point out
that
you don't know for sure that you're not
being taunted by an evil demon who wants
to give you misimpressions about the
world
and i do think you need to do a little
bit of a priori thinking just to you
know give yourself the resources to say
okay i'm gonna act as if i'm not a brain
in a vat or being fooled by an evil
demon or
you know a boltzmann brain that
spontaneously uh
randomly assemble and things like that
like none of those things
are hypotheses that you can reject just
by collecting new evidence you actually
have to think your way
out of them so there's a give and take
between the pure thinking and the
looking at the world aspects of this
yeah so in so for the 21st century if
you were to extract
the the strengths and wisdom of the
age of enlightenment and you were to
sort of promote and more deeply
integrate that
into the the minds of people today what
is it that you would extract
and promote oh i mean there's so much
really you know it's uh i mean like we
said this this
humility towards thinking about how the
world works
and if you want it's a little bit of a
well it's a huge dramatic
oversimplification of how things go
but that builds into a bayesian way of
thinking about the world
in our modern language where you say i
have a bunch of things that could be
true
i assign credences degrees of belief to
all the different possibilities i can
think of
and then i go collect new information to
update my credences and hopefully hone
in on the truth
and actually i think even though i
haven't really looked at this super
carefully
um we we haven't yet
you know within the tradition of
bayesian reasoning or fallibility or
hypothesis testing
we haven't done a good job of explaining
what
counts as new evidence that we can use
to update our beliefs like sometimes
you don't actually have any new data or
information you just
realize that something works in a
different way than you thought it did
before and your credences dramatically
shift
that's a tricky problem is that like is
that new information it's kind of new
information but it's not new data you
haven't
collected anything new about the world
but anyway okay that's that's a side
light
i think this this one idea that you know
we we don't know how the world works
we have a bunch of credences for
different possible ways it could work
and we go about updating our credences
that's one thing i would take
from the growth of the enlightenment the
other would be you know some kind of
even though this actually hasn't caught
on nearly as much some kind of fact
value
distinction right and again that's a
messy thing and people have argued
against it
uh at the margins and good
fine but i think there is some truth to
it the idea that
there are things that happen in the
world there are things that the world is
made of and there are ways that it goes
and that's what science teaches us about
you know the description of the world
and then there's a whole other realm of
evaluation and norms and judgment and
prescription what is right what is wrong
right the is ought gap and a big
believer in that is art gap and
so i think that uh figuring out how to
actually derive our ideas about or
maybe not derive but how to settle on
what we think of as our ideas about
right and wrong good and bad
needs to start with that understanding
that it's different than doing science
and looking at the world
then you know then doing and it's also
different than pure reason
so where do we ground that i think
that's something we're just very bad at
today we haven't made
nearly as much progress on that uh but
it does still grow
out of that enlightenment tradition yeah
there's this there's this great clip of
you
butting heads with with sam harris about
his
his axiom that the the
that we ought to promote the the the
greatest well-being for all
conscious creatures or no sorry it's the
uh the the greatest misery for
all sentient creatures is a bad thing
and you just keep butting your head
against them you're like well say it's
an axiom say it's an accident
like it's an assumption and he's like
well he has some view that's like
um i mean i can't restate it but he uses
some other move to try to
say that there's like no choice there's
no choice to the matter or something
yeah you know i think even though it's a
little bit uh unfair
and strong manny to say it i think it
gets the the point across
if we just sort of say look there's a
there's a move that is very very
commonly made
among people who think that they can
find absolutely foundational groundings
for morals
which is to pick a particular moral
principle and to say
surely you can't disagree with that yeah
and then you know go from there right
and build everything on the top of that
it's not just sam who does it it's a
very old
tradition and it's exactly what david
hume was making fun of back in the day
um and you know it's it's a
difficult conversation to have sometimes
because there's a difference between
ethics and meta ethics right what is
right and wrong versus how do we ground
our ideas about what is right and what
is wrong and sam is saying well
here's an idea i think is right and most
people are not going to disagree with
them most people are going to
agree yes maximizing misery would be
bad but that's an ethical thing that's
not a meta-ethical thing you haven't
told me in any way
why i should believe that or what else i
should believe or anything like that and
those are much harder questions
yeah that's right i'm quite sympathetic
to sam's view actually but i'm glad you
bring in the distinction between meta
ethics and
and normative ethics or applied ethics
um so from the age of enlightenment
we're extracting this kind of
probabilistic bayesian reasoning
we're extracting this difference between
facts and values this kind of
self uh this kind of self
um self awareness about the humility of
one's own beliefs and the
how values are often derived from from
conditioning and culture and that there
may be some
sort of more formal
or potentially formalizable uh
meta-ethical structure
uh which you you you probably you
implicitly have you don't even know you
have it
um and and that that is sort of
upstream of all of your beliefs that
you're consciously aware of and so
bringing light to that whole uh
situation is is illuminating
like ethically in terms of your
self-awareness as a as a being in a
civilization
um and
no longer taking anything is absolutely
true um
yeah you know i think that um this idea
that we should be more reflective
um about the origin of our normative
commitments
our ethical principles but also just our
you know more general ways of judging
good bad beautiful ugly uh right and
wrong and so forth
um it's a tough one to do because these
things are things about
which we have intuitions right we have
strong feelings
and i would argue that you know when we
turn these into
fancy moral philosophies really what
we're doing is just systematizing
those intuitions so you know that's
that's that is the basis on which we're
making these judgments
and people don't like that people don't
want to admit that they all have the
intuitions that they admit that
but they want to you know um ground them
in some absolutely foundational thing
just like descartes wanted to do for our
knowledge of the
external world and you know um
there's it's just gets very complicated
because the external world i think
really does exist
it's objectively out there but our
knowledge of it
does require some leaps whereas on the
moral or ethical side there's not even
anything out there
we're nothing doing nothing but leaping
and we have to become comfortable with
that and nevertheless be
a developed ways to talk to each other
to reason together to live in a society
where different people can affect
each other and being honest about meta
ethics is a good
starting point to that but a really hard
one to get people on the
on the bandwagon for yeah i mean
so i
i'm not sure how i feel about the claim
that
metaethics is just leaping from
intuitions um i mean
that would seem to be the case for any
kind of intellectual discipline
um is that we have intuitions and that
we formalize
systems that are either analytic or
synthetic based off of
those intuitions well i mean quantum
mechanics does not come about by
formalizing our intuitions
it comes about by being forced into it
by data which morality
the intuitions are
i've like the the value of evidence
the value of reason um intuitions about
mathematical axioms
that are like analytically true sure
intuitions
play a role absolutely but so does data
so does information we get from the
outside world in a way that moral axioms
are
are not uh fixed by data in the same way
well
the place where i might disagree with
that is the the consciousness itself
being
the data is this so people who take
qualia
seriously um might say that there's a
kind of ineffable
good or bad property to certain
experiences and that that is a kind of
data
i think this is the kind of move that
sam might make um
and and that is your data it's not like
evolution has just front loaded us with
intuitions that are born of game theory
but rather
there is the the interaction with
consciousness in a way that gives you
information about what is good and bad
it doesn't though it gives you
information about what is uh
pleasant or unpleasant to judge whether
it's good or bad is a separate move
some people like unpleasant sensations
yeah so that's going to quickly get into
meta ethics so we can maybe
look look back around to this um i'm
interested in kind of moving
through uh the the rest of
of of the history of thought um
though i think this is interesting and
fertile ground for a conversation
um so
all right i think it wouldn't be fun if
i if i let you get away from from
religion and mysticism without uh
talking about any of its advantages that
you might see
oh i mean i think there's plenty of
advantages you know i mean like i say in
my book the big picture um it would be
crazy to think
that for thousands of years the most
rigorous careful thought about the human
condition and what it means to be a good
person and so forth was done within
these religious traditions
and we end up with nothing useful from
that right
uh of course the boundary of what you
call a religious tradition is a little
slippery especially when you leave the
western world and go into eastern ways
of thinking
but i'm very very open to um treating
all of what has been learned and thought
about in these traditions as
potential sources of wisdom just like
i'm open to you know
treating fiction and storytelling and
biography
and good people's lives as potential
sources of wisdom
also um so you know i think that
this is part of the systematization that
i talked about you know
moral philosophy is a lot more than just
listing
our intuitions because our intuitions
are
mutually incoherent right you know
there's no rule that says that our
intuitions
form some sensible system that's why
things like trolley problems
are difficult because we have competing
intuitions that push us in different
directions
likewise when we read you know or or
experience
something from a religious tradition it
might poke us
in a way that we might otherwise not
have been poked
that makes us reflect that makes us
think you know what yeah you know i
should have uh
turned the other cheek that time right
uh
you know i should have been able to be a
better person and this this experience
that i'm reading about helps me in that
way
now can i point to very specific
examples
i don't know i mean that's hard for me
to point to specific examples because
you know our culture has been embedded
in religious traditions for thousands of
years
so much so that things that might very
well have counted as coming from a
religious tradition
have now been you know absorbed by the
greater culture so i'm not
i'm not enough of a human historian or
anthropologist to tell you
which ideas came from where all right
all right so let's let's pivot here into
into
materialism and and kind of newtonianism
which is born
uh you know and is relevant
to to the age of enlightenment so when
i'm talking about materialism here i'm
talking about
the the universe is being made of kind
of like substance it's kind of more
newtonian paradigm which is
not yet quantum physics but is uh this
kind of
substance matter uh like little tiny
stuff
uh that obeys newtonian mechanics um
so
this kind of view i'm not sure how to
so in the age of enlightenment at least
in western traditions there's this
increasing like duality between man and
world like there's this problem-solving
mindset which is being applied
to what is viewed as the external world
um
and this is also i think couched in
abrahamic religions
which um have kind of embedded
themselves in our language and view of
the world where
you're kind of visiting the universe
you're here for a short time and then
you die you like leave to go back to the
ultimate place
you have a soul um and so you're you're
visiting this place and this kind of
enlightenment thinking
is this this very dualistic
problem-solving
uh like experience with relation to the
world
so this is kind of emerging and this is
emerging alongside an increasingly
materialistic view at least among
scientific and intellectual circles
which is like okay we're all just like
stuff and matter we're basically
machines um and so this is kind of
overlooking a lot of the
the introspective and experiential and
qualitative aspect of things
uh to some degree um and what's born of
this is
like logical positivism in the early
20th century
which you can talk about perhaps the
virtues and vices of that
um and um reality from this perspective
is much more intuitive and mechanical
so what is your perspective on this kind
of shift in in paradigm
and this kind of evolution and human
intellectual thought
um as we as we're getting closer to the
present day
yeah you know i think that um it's both
important and good in some ways
and you can run too far with it in some
other ways right
it's all in contrast to what was
believed
before you know before the scientific
revolution and the enlightenment
of course you would have associated
life and thought with something that is
very different than matter
in motion obeying the laws of physics
yeah um and you would have you know
depending on what tradition you were in
you could have talked about spirit or or
whatever
uh descartes tried his best right
princess elizabeth of bohemia tried her
best to
uh let him know that he was making some
leaps that weren't quite
legitimate but still it was you know
again he was a big part of the
scientific revolution
um so i do
think that yeah so just maybe some of
the viewers here
don't know i'm a super duper physicalist
about these things
i don't believe there's any special
extra realm for thought or essence or
spirit or mind
but i don't i don't like the word i
don't choose the word materialist in
this
sense obviously one reason is that it's
been
there's a whole other definition of
materialist that has to do with you know
how much we like money and things like
that but that's okay there's also a
whole other
definition of the word naturalist that
doesn't stop me from using from using
that word
but i do think that you know you when
you talk about this newtonian point of
view
um this gets at why i think materialist
is
not a good word to describe what i am
and it wasn't even a good word
400 years ago um it sort of
leapt to a conclusion prematurely you
know the
important idea to me was the idea that
there is a
physical world right there is the
natural universe
there's no separate realm of spirits or
or
or essences or minds there's just the
physical natural world
and then it obeys some rules that we can
discover so there's sort of three
pieces to that and you could sort of
argue about them separately but they
come together to make physicalism right
there is the physical world it obeys
some rules and in principle we can
discover them
not easy to discover them but in
principle it's possible
and none of those statements is has to
do with what the
physical world is the idea that it is
objects in space-time etc
sure for isaac newton or something like
that that would have been a very natural
point of view
nowadays when we have quantum mechanics
and cosmology and a whole bunch of
things like that it's a less natural
point of view but it wasn't necessary
even for newton it wasn't
the point so i don't see some great
intellectual fissure between
the newtonian way of being a physicalist
and a modern way of being a physicalist
our idea what the physical stuff is has
changed but physicalism is still
going strong i would say um and then
yes you can also leap to some um
premature conclusions about how to think
about the relationship
between being a person and the universe
you're in some sort of cleaving
of the connection that we have with the
wider world
and you know this is just because people
always like to
leap to conclusions prematurely you know
we're
made of i would actually sort of
completely flip it around
rather than saying that this point of
view separates us from the world in some
sense
this makes us more part of the world
than we ever were we're made of the same
kind
of stuff as the world this should give
us more sympathy more empathy more
connection
to the world around us because we're not
that special we're just
ordinary stuff doing some extraordinary
things
yeah that makes yeah i totally agree um
so
by materialism i'm trying to
specifically invoke the
the the the substance matter thing
rather than the
how quantum physics kind of does away
with that view
um where we have this this universal
wave function
um and this is yeah but my point is that
that's not a big distinction that this
shift from
a newtonian view where there's space and
there's time and there's stuff
to a quantum view where there's a wave
function in abstract hilbert space
in my view that's a very tiny shift you
know it's
in the kind of shift that might happen
again another dozen times in the history
of physics in the future as we discover
more and more things
what the physical world is the specific
mathematics
or or formal system that we use to
describe it
is way less important to me than the
idea that there is a physical world that
obeys rules that we can discover
yeah so that makes total sense like
physicalism is just like there's a world
there's no supernatural stuff and it all
obeys the laws of physics
and there's this but but the sense in
which it is relevant
is something that we'll touch on a
little bit later is you get
this revitalization of certain
metaphysical views in spiritual and
religious traditions
because it goes from being cold dead
matter to being
this kind of like empty wave vibration
stuff
that you can make a movie like what the
bleep about
that just totally steals all the quantum
physics
and uses it to justify unsubstantiated
metaphysical views for example and so
people believe all sorts of wrong things
today
because of this movement from
materialism to to quantum mechanics
and perhaps they also reject i mean
most people most people probably don't
believe in pure physicalism
um because most people are are religious
and so there is some supernatural
component
um
so the reason why i also feel that this
this so you said that
i was talking about this kind of duality
between man and nature that was kind of
born of this and you said that early on
that
that is actually i'm sorry i don't i
don't mean to interrupt you but let me
can i say something about what the bleep
etc before we move on to yeah
go ahead yeah uh you know i do think
that you're absolutely right obviously
that um people co-opted the language of
quantum mechanics
to uh push all sorts of non-physicalist
uh ways of thinking about the world and
but that's just a mistake
like that's not an interesting move it's
just that
no i understand but i i blame my own
people i blame physicists for this
in a very real sense because we didn't
face up
to the reality of trying to understand
quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics is different and weird
it's it's a
different kind of physical theory than
we had ever had before it's not just yet
another physical theory it's a different
kind of theory
and the way it's different is that when
we teach quantum mechanics or when we
read about the rules of quantum
mechanics in the works of heisenberg and
bourne
uh bohr etc the idea of measuring or
looking or observing
the at the world is part of the
fundamental
description of the theory and given that
it's kind of very sensible that people
would
leap to all sorts of crazy conclusions
about the role of the observer
and the mind and so forth and what
but people haven't yet been told and
we're trying to tell them
is that that was something that you know
we we talked about
80 years ago but we don't talk about it
that much anymore there are
absolutely purely physicalist ways of
thinking about quantum mechanics that
are a hundred percent in agreement with
the data there's
there are videos out there on youtube
you can find them that say
as we all know quantum mechanics tells
us that idealism was right all along and
we create the world by looking at it
and that's very much in the spirit of
what the bleep do we know etc but those
videos are all wrong they're just
mistaken and so as physicists we need to
do a better job
of pointing out that there's no rupture
between physicalism and quantum
mechanics
all right i might i might i might put i
might put up some defense of
non-materialist physicalist idealism
sometime later um but so my project here
is to i think uh reflect on the
strengths and weaknesses of the 21st
century
mind and how we got here and so we've
touched on some of the weaknesses of say
spirituality and religion and i'm i was
trying to evoke
again how it's how it fails in the face
of
the weakness in which uh
the human mind can kind of latch on to
spooky things that are hard to
understand in physics and use it to
justify
uh one's own meta-ethical or sorry not
meta-ethical
metaphysical views um so
pivoting back to we'll call it
physicalism
like newtonian physicalism i'll stop
using the word materialism
um other things that i think
so you mentioned how people latch onto
things
before we know enough to really develop
a sophisticated view
and so one of these we were talking
about the sort of duality between man
and world where we have this world model
of ourself as kind of like a machine
embedded in a machine
and um
we're not identical to ultimate reality
itself
which may track back to
abrahamic religions and the kind of
world view that they have but there are
also other things that i see
as this sort of being reflected
in how this kind of science and
atheism and and physicalism has been
promoted and perhaps uh
worked its way through the minds of
people in the early 21st century
so their ideas like free will so free
will from the
from this like a naive view of free will
from this kind of physicalist newtonian
paradigm
would be that it doesn't exist yet this
becomes more
nuanced as we get forms of like
compatibilism
um now that's an upgrade because it
rejects
uh what is the word the the spooky
the spooky kind of free will um
libertarian yeah libertarian free will
that's right um so it's an upgrade
because it's rejecting libertarian free
will
um yet
there's a sense in which this view is i
think
if one takes this naive view of free
will and one takes this sort of
dualistic view of of self and world that
is born of this physical newtonian view
it leads to a lot of like suffering um
which i mean i can speak for myself that
i feel
like less happy or like there's less
well-being in my life
from i like i no longer hold these views
in the way that i once did but um
i'm trying to point out a disadvantage
to
the the a potential consequence
of the experience of a human being in
this life
given accepting some of these views
um yeah so do you have what do you think
well i certainly think that um it's
interesting
there's sort of two things pushing in
different directions here
one is i'm not going to deny
that we might reach certain conclusions
about how the world works
that make us sad i mean it would be the
most surprising thing in the world if
the progress of science taught us more
and more about the world and every
single discovery made us happier
uh the example that i just most
obviously use is i would like there to
be life after death you know i'm not
happy with the idea
that i will cease to exist a few decades
or years or moments hence depending on
how things go
uh but i accept it you know i think that
it's it's the right way to think about
the world
um and the but the countervailing idea
is
you know people have a very natural uh
predisposition
to uh see the sunny side of whatever
world view
they have so whenever they invent a new
world view they try to
explain why in fact it's better right in
fact it's actually you know very
liberating and so forth
and i think and i i feel that uh and i
want to sort of
resist it because i know it's a
temptation it's a cognitive bias to sort
of you know
um paint your existing situation as
what you wanted all along right you know
the fox and the grapes
um but this also it might also be true
that a new world view has some positive
aspects to it
so to me the fact that you know life
exists for a typical human being
for a century or less is too bad i'm not
going to say it's better
than the alternative but there are good
aspects of it right i mean it makes the
moments that we have here in the world
more precious if you think that this is
the world that we have this is the life
that we have to experience it's not just
a dress rehearsal
for something coming up after the fact
so it's not in my mind
our place to argue that you know first
figure out what's true
and then expose facto say and and that's
the best of all possible worlds
but it is our place to say okay this is
true and let's find the good aspects of
it
yeah so i'm not trying to say in some
sense the the
the the the truth has to always make us
happy
in in a sense yet i think there there's
this there's this claim in wisdom
traditions for example
that some some that
like the truth is ultimately liberating
or i think some kind of more
conventional
truth some more conventional wisdom is
like the truth will
set you free uh that one's a little
cringy for some reason to me
um uh but
the and so when i was talking about free
will or the newtonian view like those
aren't necessarily true depending on how
sophisticated your understanding is of
them
um but i i see this tension here between
what you're saying is like yes the like
the truth doesn't have to conform with
what we expect or want of reality
yet at the same time there seems to be
the strength and wisdom traditions which
says that like
even if that's the case and you're
suffering now because it doesn't seem to
be the way that you wanted it to be it
will ultimately
like be it will ultimately pacify you
in some in some deep sense well i think
you know i think it's actually
a very difficult fascinating uh thing to
think about
because i i would like to claim i'm not
completely sure this is true but i would
like to claim that nobody
wants to be misled at the moment right
no one wants to actively say
please tell me false things that will
make me happy right
we do that to other people we decide for
them
that they'd be better off being misled
right we keep unpleasant truths from
them but they
never ask us to do that now the one
loophole here is
uh it takes me back to a podcast i did
with lori paul who's a philosopher who
talks about transformative experiences
and really emphasizing the fact that me
now
is not me sometime in the future i mean
maybe
me now is closely related to me sometime
in the future
and the transformative yeah but the but
the transformative experience idea
is that maybe me now is radically
different than me in the future and you
know the silly example is you turn into
a vampire
and your wants and desires change but
really the down-to-earth examples are
getting married having children going to
graduate school
things like that so i might imagine a
dramatic situation
in which i choose now to mislead my
future self
right um i don't think i would want that
but i can imagine
uh you know in principle that that's
that's a possible thing
so i think that whether or not the truth
sets you free so that was basically an
elaborate caveat but other than that
caveat
um i think that whether or not the truth
sets you free the truth is something we
want
you know even you know when we talk
these days about fake news and people
who are in their filter bubbles and
believe crazy things and so forth
none of them no one says i
intentionally only uh expose myself to
fake news so that i can
uphold my crazy world view like they
think they're right right people think
that they're being accurate
and people want to be accurate and so i
don't think it's that the truth sets you
free i think is that you know we
all think that we should have the truth
and then we will cope with it whatever
way we can
yeah so i think the so okay but i also
think that the claim
the the claim runs deeper than that and
i'm not sure that we're going to be able
to come up with reasons and argument
here for it
it's more of like a experiential
hypothesis that i think wisdom
traditions propose
but it's not just that you will get what
you want by getting the truth because
people ultimately want the truth it's
also that you may suffer on your way
there because you may have to
abandon your identity and abandon how
you used to model yourself in the world
but that there's not coping afterwards
there is
there is this there is like pure pure
pacification
um yeah so that's that's a hypothesis
and that runs very deep
and you have to sort of embark on the
journey
to see if that's true yeah and i suspect
it's often not true
i mean i think it's a little bit of
wishful thinking going on there uh
so i i but i think it's nevertheless a
value
to have an accurate view of the world
that would be my hypothesis whether or
not
it sets us free or makes us happy or
something we can cope with we want it
anyway i want it anyway
okay sure all right so um
all right
okay why so
why do you think that that's not true i
just don't see any necessary
relationship
between the truth and any positive
value uh that i might have in terms of
happiness or experience or or anything
like that you know the truth can be
depressing the truth can make you sad i
just don't see any reason why
that wouldn't be the case yeah
but i want it anyway yeah yeah
so maybe maybe i'll table that one for
now um
yeah i still experience yeah i i have
some like deep intuitive tension between
like understanding what you are saying
and then there's the juxtaposition
between
pick your favorite historic like
awakened historical figure and
the kind of experience that they lead um
and there's
there's this convergence between these
sort of
uh examples of human life
there's this convergence on this kind of
claim
go ahead i mean there's there is a
counter claim
you know uh owen flanagan who's a
philosopher uh
at duke university points out to me he
has he says when he goes into his class
he says you know think about
the historical figures that have really
in for whatever in your personal view
have made the world a better place
right whether it's jesus or florence
nightingale or
gandhi or martin luther king so think
about
them personally as human beings
do you think that they were happy he
says
and you know maybe they were or maybe
they weren't but happiness is not the
first thing that comes to mind
uh they were struggling to make the
world a better place
and i think that uh i think that's you
know there is this temptation
to say that one good thing is every good
thing that good things just go along
with each
other and i think it's a little bit more
honest to say you know
good things can be in tension with each
other
knowing the truth doesn't make us
happier making the world a better place
uh isn't easy or you know fulfilling
personally it might be great sacrifice
and i think that's okay and i think that
means that we need to make choices
and facing up to those choices is part
of the human condition
um let's talk about let's talk about
quantum physics
um so there's the subversion here then
of materialism
um which you said you didn't like that
word but so
quantum physics is continuing this this
physicalist paradigm
um and we already talked about how
this the bad epistemology of certain
religious and spiritual traditions
kind of co-ops the the quantum physics
to justify
certain claims um
and there's now this this violation of
our intuitions whereas before the kind
of newtonian mechanics is in accordance
with the human conventional
ontology and now it's like well actually
the fundamental ontology
is is is wave like
is is kind of probability distributed um
and actually like fundamentally empty
and spacious in the kind of space-time
sense of of it um
how do you how do you view this shift in
relation to the previous shifts
and how we should be thinking about
relating to that in the 21st century
well i think that quantum mechanics is a
more dramatic break
from previous physical theories about
the fundamental nature of reality
but every theory has some breaks in it
you know
you say that newtonian mechanics matches
up with our intuition well
tell it to students learning tony
mechanics for the first time right the
idea that
without being pushed things move on a
straight line at a constant velocity
is highly non-intuitive we really need
to think our way through that and
even once you learn the rules you know
figuring out
what a certain thing does on an inclined
plane or whatever is not necessarily
obvious
the distinction between waves and
particles the second law of
thermodynamics and entropy and
probability and fluctuations
relativity saying that simultaneity is
not an absolute concept
all of these are dramatic uh
dramatically at variance with our
intuitions
so that's why i'm saying that quantum
mechanics wasn't really different of a
kind it was just
different in amount of difference
between it and previous ontologies of
reality it was a dramatic difference but
it's just one in a long line of
differences
that might continue toward the future
it's not to underplay it
it's so dramatic that now 90 years later
almost or more than 90 years later after
putting quantum mechanics together
um the experts in the field don't agree
on what it says
right and that's something that is that
is
rare and embarrassing even in the
history of physics we have hundreds of
people thousands of people thinking at a
deep level about what this physical
theory says
and we don't agree on what the theory
itself is
much less all of its applications etc
that wasn't true for newtonian mechanics
or relativity or anything like that
so quantum mechanics is really harder
than everything else but it's still
physicalism at the end of the day
no matter how misused it can possibly be
right so there's there's this so
you you have a lot of um i imagine well
i mean i've heard you say
uh i mean it's not
you believe in the deep power and
elegance of physicalism
given the the track the track history of
the scientific epistemology
and and uh falsification and and
verificationism
uh with relation to empirical
observation and the construction of
theories
um and so
in the so there still exists though
kind of superstitious and wishful
thinking in
the the the 21st century it's almost as
if people don't
see that the processes in the world are
kind of
inexhaustibly explained by
the the forces of physics and so
there seems to be this the space for
something else and that that space
is insert your favorite like
metaphysical view that isn't in science
there's enough room there so how would
you
how would you try to make that how would
you try to shrink that space
or to try to improve the the
epistemology and thinking of people
today
given the belief that that space exists
yeah you know i think that uh i mean
it's a very good point and obviously
consciousness is the one place where
there's plenty of very very smart people
who uh declined to go all the way to
being pure physicalists
uh for various reasons various arguments
uh david chalmers's hard
problem and the zombie argument but
other people
have various ways of getting to the
conclusion that
mere physical stuff will never be enough
to account for consciousness
so here's how i would put it you know
number one
physicalism has been incredibly
successful at everything else
right like if you even if you know even
if you're david chalmers
you you completely buy that you know
there's not ghosts and demons out there
that we can explain
the universe and what it does in purely
physicalist terms
um furthermore it's it's
very hard to come up with any sensible
alternative to thinking of the mind and
its manifestations as a physicalist and
this goes back to
princess elizabeth and the international
in the interaction problem right like
if you say there is something that you
need in addition to the physical stuff
then you have to face up to the fact
that we have a theory describing what
the physical stuff does
right given the fact that there are
electrons and protons and neutrons in
your brain
we have physics that says what that
stuff is going to do and that includes
pushing around your breath and your
tongue to make sounds and make words and
express your inner life
okay so if you don't believe
that physics is sufficient to account
for that
then you need to tell me why our laws of
physics are
wrong because they make unambiguous
predictions and you're saying if that's
not enough you're saying those laws are
wrong
and so how does this ineffable stuff
somehow
push around my tongue and my breath to
make me say different sounds than i
would say
if i were in a purely physical world and
finally i would point out that
if physicalism were correct right if it
were just stuff
moving around in complicated ways what
is the thing
that would be the hardest to account for
what is the thing that we would account
for
last in our working through all the
difficult things in the world
well it would be the human brain because
that really is
the most complex structure that we know
about
in the universe so it is zero surprise
that physics as yet or physicalism even
has not completely accounted for
everything that human beings do
in terms of their consciousness and
their thought and things like that of
course we haven't done that yet it's
hard
that's not evidence it's not doable it's
just gonna take time
so i would think that you know there's a
huge preponderance of evidence that says
it's by far the simplest most
reasonable hypothesis that someday we
will
entirely account for consciousness on
the basis of physical stuff
that's not to say we know for sure we
haven't done it yet
but it's absolutely the way to bet yeah
so
this is making me think of your
conversation with with philip gough
um and i think another aspect of this
here is that if someone doesn't have
this history of science and
how the like like the completeness of
physics
at this current point in time if
something happens and it seems kind of
uh like a miracle or something um that
seems to be outside the bounds of the
physical theories from that kind of
first person experiential point of view
whereas you know really the world is a
large complex system
and unusual things happen every day um
and and the failure to kind of integrate
uh that perspective with something that
seems unique or strange
gives credence to these unsubstantiated
metaphysical views that then leads to
this kind of
poor epistemology and many other places
from politics to
conspiracy theories and everything else
so
i i really do want to get into the
philip gough stuff because i think it's
really interesting in terms of this
tension between the qualitative and
quantitative when you talk about the
application
of physicalism or
and the kind of scientific method
because you're saying so the the human
brain for example is the most
complicated known object in the universe
in the known universe um and we have
this first person
uh conscious experience and you say you
feel confident
that because we have this
ever-increasing body of scientific
knowledge
that this most complex object is you
know it's it's the last thing
uh to figure out before the the sphere
of scientific knowledge kind of
encompasses it
um
yet what so
taking kind of the position of philip
gough here
or the the the i i might even put up a
bit of a defensive idealism here
um is that understanding is like an
increasingly
that would just be like fully that
sounds like fully mapping the neural
correlates of consciousness
and you have this view where you say
so so there's a thought experiment of
what is it mary
yeah maybe the color scientist mary is
the colorblind scientist
who lives in a black and white room and
she's never experienced the color red
and so from a strictly like personal
conscious consciousness perspective
there's the claim that
she's missing some kind of information
about
what the actual qualitative color of red
looks like
from the perspective of consciousness
whereas she could understand the entire
neural and causal structure at the level
of underlying physics of
uh the wavelength of the light and how
that goes in is processed by the brain
david chalmers refers to that as the
easy problems of consciousness
um and so
it seems like you're justified you're
saying that that and so sorry your view
is that um so i'm not trying to speak
for you here but your view as i
understand it
is that if you give
her the information about the neural
correlates of red and then you
instantiate it in her that's how you
transfer the full information of what
redness is
well i would i would just try to you
know be more careful about the idea of
what redness is and that information you
know i think that the
the argument is supposed to be frank
jackson is the one who originally came
up with the argument and he later
said it doesn't work he himself went
back on it
the idea is you know mary's is locked in
this in this black and white room
but she reads up on everything that
there is to know about the color red and
so there's literally no fact about red
that she doesn't know
so goes the argument except that when
she goes outside the room and sees the
color
red she now experiences what it is like
to see the color red and she knows
something now that she didn't know
before namely
what it is like to see the color red
okay
um so i i just think that that's playing
around with language in in
a different way i mean yes it is is
different
to experience seeing the color red than
to
know a lot of facts in science textbooks
about the color red
that just does xero work for me for to
show that
you know human consciousness is not
physical it's a different thing
you know you experience red versus
learning some facts about it but
i can account for both of those things
by physical stuff moving around in your
brain
i think i think that's basically what
jackson himself eventually concluded
right so
there's so that hmm
so so to say consciousness is physical
is to say that it's governed by
the the laws of physics and so there's a
perspective like non-materialist
physicalist idealism which is a big
string of jargon
so non-materialist means like there's
not material stuff it's kind of more
it's kind of taking on more of the
perspective of quantum mechanics it's
physicalist by saying that consciousness
is purely described by the laws of
physics
there's a sense in which um the laws of
physics
uh inexhaustibly describe
the world like the there's this very
there's really not much room
for for for say consciousness for
example to have causal efficacy
because then you would wonder like well
there's some variable in the equations
that's missing
um right so
but but but there's still the
metaphysical question which is
more like the hard problem which is like
why are these
why do these correlates of so why do
these neural correlates or why does this
causal structure give rise to
the the qualitative experience of red
which is distinct from the
sort of quantitative theory yeah and so
this is where i would you know try to
explain things in terms of different
vocabularies for talking about the world
different levels of
description so i would certainly never
say that consciousness has no causal
efficacy
in the world me being conscious of
something might very well affect how i
act about it
what i would say is if i'm trying to
explain how i behave in the world
in terms of my beliefs my conscious
experiences my reactions to them
my desires etc that's just a different
way of talking about the world and
explaining the world in terms of
electrons and protons and neutrons and
the laws of physics
and those two ways must ultimately be
compatible
but i can use either one of them
independently
but they're you know they're they're
over complete in a sense i don't need to
tell you
what all the electrons and protons and
neutrons are doing and
tell you about consciousness and beliefs
and predispositions i can
get use either vocabulary perfectly well
and so there's no there's no um
incompatibility in my mind
at all to saying that you know
consciousness is real
we have thoughts we have experiences we
we have
uh ideas about what it is like to see
the color red etc
and we're a big wave function in
hilbert's space
evolving according to the schrodinger
equation those aren't two
things that are in competition with each
other there's just two different
vocabularies to describe the same
situation
right i the the thing here that seems to
be
maybe escaping me or the where there's
kind of
the desire for clarity is around the the
metaphysical status
so in the non-materialist physicalist
idealism
it's the the solution to like why there
is consciousness is because
there is this uh like
the ground of being to to physicalism is
is consciousness itself
and so like human beings are identical
to
fundamental reality and when
like so fundamental reality like
privately from like within the inside
is aware um
and has a qualitative nature to it which
seems to be in tension
with the quantitative descriptions that
we can give
about the the causal structure that
underlies the
the qualitative aspects and so and it
seems to be of a different kind
and so there's this question about like
the metaphysical status which
seems not to be answered by by
by say quantum physics or whatever else
well certainly not by quantum physics i
don't think quantum physics has anything
necessarily to do with it but i just
don't think that idealism
uh survives confrontation with the real
world
very effectively you know you start with
the idea that
mind or consciousness is fundamental
and you're the huge barrier to pushing
that forward is the fact that
the external non-conscious world
seems to be objectively real and highly
complex and independent
of our mind we human beings experience
the world
and there are aspects of it we wouldn't
have guessed
and we learn about them and they're the
same for all of us
so at the very least you have to say in
addition to
minds and consciousness there is some
physical objective
outside of consciousness reality that
that is able to be experienced by us
and then you realize that if you believe
in that you don't need to believe in the
minds and consciousness as being special
they can just be aspects of that
physical reality so
i i don't think that you know uh it just
the idea that
we have internal conscious experiences
therefore
somehow by some chain of logic we need
to include that as a category in our
ontology
just doesn't seem to give have much
purchase for me
right so i so i think that the the
non-materialist physicalist view though
is that the that there isn't an external
sorry it's there's like there is
fundamental reality
but the ground of that reality is all
mind so you're saying that there is this
fun
there's this external reality outside of
mind but
the view is actually that like the
ground of that is just more mind
and and it's it's isomorphic to
to uh like physicalism and like the laws
of physics
it's inexhaustibly the mind is
inexhaustibly described by physics
it just seems to be to be wildly
unhelpful to do that
i mean if i can just say there's a
physical world that obeys these laws
what am i gaining by saying there is a
notion of mine not like an actual
mind in someone's brain right but some
much more inevitable metaphysical thing
mindiness that contains all of that
physical reality
uh seems to be entirely backwards in
terms of explanatory elegance in my view
right
but it the place that i see that is
helpful is it explains
why i for example being identical to
fundamental reality i'm having
a an experience
so could you explain like what your
perspective then is on
on consciousness and how it arises and
what its ontological or metaphysical
relationship is
well i think that at the level of our
vocabulary for talking about human
beings
um consciousness is an extraordinarily
useful
idea extraordinarily useful category you
know the thought experiment of
being alien and coming down and
observing human beings
and you know you see them talk to each
other you say you know you hear them
feeling
you know saying oh i'm sad i'm happy
about this oh i had a you know i saw red
yesterday
in your in the in the theory that you
would develop for what a human being is
you would invent all sorts of internal
states right
and you would eventually you know come
up with some word
for all of these different feelings and
experiences that these human beings had
and that word might be consciousness i
mean of course you can't get through the
day
thinking about human beings without
attributing consciousness
to them but that has nothing to do
with whether or not that consciousness
is explicable in terms of physical terms
or not
um you know there's plenty of other
other things that we
categories that we use that are higher
level
intrinsically and yet are perfectly
compatible with underlying
physicalism um you know in fact i would
go
here's how far i would go i think that
you know the idea of zombies which
chalmers introduced
um which which he says you know imagine
that there is
not necessarily in our world but just
conceivably
there are physical things that are atom
for adam copies of us
that act in exactly the same way as us
but don't have internal uh experience
right are not consciousness
are not conscious right and he says just
because i can conceive of that
if i can then clearly consciousness has
to be something
in addition to the physical stuff
because they just said the physical
stuff is exactly the same but it doesn't
have consciousness
but look my attitude is this is a
wonderful argument in favor of
physicalism yeah let's hear it
because i talk to the zombie you know i
have a zombie you know you promise me
this person is a zombie they are
they're physically acting exactly like a
human being would
but they have no internal consciousness
so i asked them about their internal
consciousness i asked them about seeing
the color red
feeling pain all of these things they
give me exactly the same answers
that a human being would okay that's
right that's the point
they act exactly the same so therefore
but i but i know somehow god told me
that they don't
really have any internal experiences
right
so therefore they're wrong
they think that they have internal
experiences otherwise they wouldn't be
lying to me
but they're completely wrong about
having those internal experiences
therefore the conclusion is the
introspection
of the zombies is completely unreliable
right they they do their best to think
like they're like yeah i saw that red it
was very vivid it really made me angry
right
just like a human being would but
they're completely wrong about that
therefore i have zero reason to think
that human beings
are any more accurate when they
introspect and tell me that they have
internal conscious
states their feelings about them are
exactly the same as a zombie would have
and therefore the only argument against
physicalism is completely undermined by
the idea that there could be zombies
so so if to summarize that it's that
those worlds are indistinguishable
because there's no
epistemic tool for
saying whether or not you're actually
conscious because they're causally
isomorphic so you wouldn't know whether
or not you were in the conscious world
or the unconscious world
it's basically that but it's a tiny bit
stronger than that the
only evidence that you have that there
is something called consciousness over
and above the physical world
you've just argued is completely
unbelievable
it's completely unreliable so there's
zero evidence
sorry i don't understand if you think
that there can be zombies
yeah that that give you uh
that tell you all about their inner
experiences
yes but don't have it but don't have it
then you
must believe that the connection between
uh inner experiences and what you say
about them what you report about them
what you
think about them is entirely 100
unreliable
yeah yeah that's what i that's what i
meant to say um
is yeah is that the report is on is
completely unreliable
because the report is the same in both
cases right um
yeah so i think that's a really good
objection actually um
and even in non-materialist physicalist
idealism
um if if if the laws of nature
actually but if there's an isomorphism
between
red and the neural correlates
that structure and are related to red
then the brain could be pointing towards
that neural architecture and the
experience could be
pointing towards that qualia and there
would still be an isomorphism there and
so that's how you would be able to
communicate about it in like a non
non-physicalist materialist idealism
does that make sense
well i'm not sure that it does i mean
what's the difference between i mean
those neurocarotids would
also exist in the zombie yeah they would
so you're just adding a completely
inefficacious extra category to your
ontology for no good reason
well that was okay so so you haven't so
there's no
so consciousness for you then is a
is part of our i think you you use the
phrase folk ontology
that's right yeah so you think
consciousness so it sounds more like
can you tell me why this isn't
anti-realism
consciousness exists it's real i talk
about it all the time
just like you know i ask this question
to people like sam harris who don't
believe in free will
uh like have you never tried to make a
difficult decision
you know do you really just say well let
the laws of physics do what they're
going to do
of course at the level where we talk
about
people we attribute choices
and volition to them like we treat
attribute
conscious experiences to them and i'm
all in favor of that i think
that they exist they're real they should
be treated as such
that doesn't provide any evidence at all
that they are not isomorphic to physical
things going on in the universe
yeah so your so your perspective is that
we have this kind of conventional
ontology which
is um a kind of fabricated layer which
we impose upon reality
that is consisted of tables and chairs
and people and free will
and consciousness and clouds and
galaxies and stuff
um and so that's kind of this this layer
of understanding and you talk about
there being layers
um you have chemistry and biology and
physics and quantum physics
um and
did they map to each other in some way i
think is
is how you describe it is they're not
incompatible because there is this
there's this relationship between them
that is well and
even more than that there's nothing
fabricated about them i mean there's
tables and chairs really do exist
there's a difference between
explaining things and explaining them
away the chair doesn't stop
existing when i realize it's made of
atoms
okay so
but the the
okay so i think the distinction here
between and this is relevant to
consciousness which i'll get into in a
second
is for example so you have this view
where free will
is um you're not a fan of sam's take on
free will free will being an illusion
so what sam is arguing against in my
understanding is he's arguing against
libertarian free will
which i'm sure you wouldn't agree with
right
uh i do not agree with libertarian free
will yeah you don't agree with
libertarian free will
yet the the the yet the in within the
folk ontology or like the folk
experience of a human being we
experience ourselves
as having libertarian free will like
when we're
when we're deciding whether to pick up
my wallet or my phone it feels like
libertarian free will
and sam's coming along and he's like
keep doing that
because that's the difference between
living a life as fatalism as you
described it like saying oh i'm just
gonna let the laws of physics
take over but that's kind of an error
because
this libertarian experience is still
couched and run
on the fundamental physics so it's it's
isomorphic to it
and it's how agents make decisions like
uh between objects yet what sam is
saying
is that do that but realize that it's a
kind of
fabrication that it's the the the that
ultimately you're identical to the laws
and quantum physics is governing the
whole thing but you're going to have
this kind of fabricated experience on
top
that is not actually the thing and so
it's conventional and so
do you want to jump in well i just think
that all of these words like fabrication
and error and illusion are completely
misplaced
in this context the higher level
emergent patterns are
incredibly real they're there they
didn't have to be there
you could imagine alternative laws of
physics where the higher level immersion
patterns just
aren't there at all or just take on very
very different forms
to say that tables and chairs exist
is a true interesting non-trivial fact
about the world
just as saying that free will and
consciousness exist is a true
interesting non-trivial fact about the
world and we'd be dopey not to recognize
it
right but there's there's the sense that
human beings experience the table as a
kind of platonic thing
and so when people say like the table
doesn't exist as a table they're saying
like don't look at the table as like a
platonic thing
like the the table is a pattern right
yeah so the uh when you say like people
in their everyday lives
imagine they have libertarian free will
i don't know
i don't really necessarily care they
imagine they're making choices that's
all i care about whether or not they
imagine that they are
yeah that they have the ability to buy
the laws of physics while making those
choices i don't think that that's
actually part of their decision making
process
i think that's like setting up a straw
man to knock down they're
making choices and that's what matters
yeah so okay
yeah and i mean that's the way i use the
word free will um
so but so consciousness is but but
consciousness seems of a different kind
to me it would be very forget about very
weird it would be impossible
to talk about the human scale world
if you literally removed from your
vocabulary
any idea that human beings had free will
or that human beings were conscious
that's the evidence that these things
are real they
play an important non-trivial
non-extricable role
in our best way of talking about the
world at that level
it sounds okay i don't want to get
caught on this for too long
um you know you see how you mentioned
let me mention one thing like when i was
talking with sam about it
you know he kept coming back to this
point uh which people often come back to
but if you were laplace's demon if you
knew the exact positions of every atom
in your body and you knew what was going
to happen next then you wouldn't have
free will
yeah sure that's completely true
but you're not lost as a demon and you
will never be
if you were laplace's demon you wouldn't
need to talk about tables and chairs
either but we're not we literally cannot
be
we don't have the capacity to do that
let's face up to the
limited view of the world that we have
and within that view the vocabulary of
being conscious and making choices is
both very important
yeah it is important in its functional
uh
the the but there's this but again
there's the tension between
being a physicalist and knowing that
your choices are
basically just physics running
like playing out and the experience of
that being kind of
libertarian and so sam's like it's not
libertarian it's like physicalism
and you're like oh well that's not my
experience of the world and and
and it looks similarly it's like
yeah there are tables and chairs which
are like patterns of physical phenomena
but they're not like
platonic independent entities that are
like fundamentally different from you
but
so i think there's two things that i
could say to that i mean one is i
just don't think that most people
when they go through the world making
decisions are
really uh wedded to the idea that those
decisions are independent of the laws of
physics i think they just don't think
about that they just don't care they
just make decisions
yeah and the second thing is if you
really wanted to insist that people make
a choice
about whether or not their decisions
were compatible with the laws of physics
or not
and only that would count as free will
go nuts be my guest you know whatever
words you want to use to describe it
i'm still going to think about people as
making choices that's what matters to me
not whether it's libertarian or not okay
can you what does it mean for something
to be real for you
and what do you mean when you say that
consciousness is real
it's part of an algorithmically
compressed description of the world that
gives us insight into what happens what
the world is doing and what happens
about it when we talk about
well how will this person react to the
following news i will give them
the idea that well it will make them sad
or it'll make them happy
is kind of important i can't i think
that abandoning those ideas would give
us a
worse description of the world rather
than a better one
is are fundamental forces of nature
algorithmically compressed descriptions
yeah sure
they're okay it is space time an
algorithmically compressed description
yep so so
in this in this view all
all phenomena that we can define and
name are algorithmically compressed
descriptions
well there is in in my view there's
something called the world there's
reality
okay i don't know what it is uh i have
guesses
as to what it might be but i model
it right i pick out aspects of it
and i describe them and i talk about
their relationship and where they might
go in the future maybe
definitively or maybe just
probabilistically and i can do that at
various levels of resolution
right and it's useful to me you know my
favorite example is just
the motion of the earth around the sun
given the mass of the sun
and given the mass of the earth and
their velocities all i need to tell you
is the center of mass
location of the earth and the sun to
tell you how the earth will move
i don't need to tell you the location of
every atom
in the earth that is information i don't
need i have a highly compressed
description of that
now you can say well the center of mass
of the earth isn't real
the only thing that's real is all the
atoms it's made out of you know bless
your heart go ahead and do that
i'm still going to use this way more
efficient description it gives me
real insight about the world that is
that is a non-trivial feature of the
laws of nature
and i can say all of those things about
people making choices and people having
experiences
is the description complete though when
it doesn't include
um when it doesn't include for example
like laws and principles that are
included in quantum mechanics
no of course it's not complete i mean
almost you
all of our ways of talking about the
world will be incomplete
that doesn't mean that they're not right
or useful
right so i think there's this difference
between truth and useful
so it's like that theory is like
approximate but if it doesn't take into
account
um you know things that happen in
quantum mechanics that might subvert
that model
then it's it's it's accurate but not
true
well that's a that's a perfectly you
know then we're just talking about
definitions and that's a definition of
true
but it's a definition of true under
which we will never
in the future of all history ever be
able to say anything is true
because we can never know for sure that
there's not a hidden description
underneath that doesn't require a lot
more information that we don't have
so you're welcome to that definition i
just don't think it's a very useful one
yeah i think you have an interesting
i mean so this kind of makes you think
of anthony aguirre
who talks about you know
reality is fundamentally being
information you're talking
here about like what counts as real as
being this kind of algorithmic
compressibility of
of of of levels of reality
um and
it leaves me st i i i it it it leaves me
confused about
um yeah
the the metaphysical status of certain
things i mean people want like is this
thing
true as a third person objective fact
and this this this participating in
modeling the world
by by saying can i algorithmic
algorithmically compress this thing is
i mean it's kind of it's it's it's it's
bringing out this
this fact that we can't escape
the fact that we have to do that yet
i'm like so my reaction is like okay
sean but like
is con like was consciousness there at
the very beginning like is it part of
the
the the fire and the equations of
physics
like why is it here to begin with um
i find the yeah so yeah
so i think that daniel dennett has a
good way of thinking about this in terms
of what he calls
real patterns and the word real is doing
a lot of
work there and it's the fact that
we have these very very compressed
useful but not a hundred percent
accurate ways of talking about the world
again is a highly non-trivial fact about
the world
take again the earth moving around the
sun when you when you construct the
center of mass
of the earth you take the locations
and the masses of every particle and you
average them okay and then you get
one number so you're throwing away an
enormous amount of information all the
relative positions of all these
different particles okay
and that tiny bit of information you're
left with
is still incredibly useful it tells you
where the earth's going to go right
whereas if you cho chose almost
any other way of throwing away that much
information
let's say instead of the positions you
average the
uh you know the positions of half of the
atoms and the momentum the other half
right
you would get a number but it would be
completely useless so it'd be completely
non-predictive it wouldn't tell you
anything about the world
so it has nothing to do with our human
convenience
there is a real physical fact about the
world
that you can approximately model it
using this
incredibly tiny amount of the data that
in principle you would absolutely need
so is consciousness there at the
beginning of the world no
but the possibility of consciousness
existing was always there it was
the fact that if i tell you someone is
sad
that just doesn't convey the word sad it
conveys to you a whole bunch of
information that you instantly know
that's why it's a useful feature useful
real character of the world
yeah that make yeah i'm at the limits of
my
my understanding here so um
it's um
[Music]
yeah yeah i mean so so there is that
capacity
um but it's like it's like you're saying
you're so like there's quantum physics
and there's newtonian physics
and neuftonian physics abstracts away
certain things
but it's still accurate right so you
just gave this example of the
of the earth rotating around the sun and
the center of mass there there's a
similar analogy between quantum physics
and newtonian physics
and so you're saying for example
newtonian physics is
is pretty is real uh in the denit sense
because it's this strong pattern feature
of reality it's non-trivial
that newtonian physics works right
didn't have to be that way that's right
it captures something real it captures
something real
like you know the the joke that i
sometimes tell is
if you go on a date with someone your
first date and they say
tell me about yourself do you give them
a list of all your atoms and their
positions and velocities
no i mean you could do that but
not only is it impractical because you
don't know it it actually
is not useful yes what would you do with
that
whereas if you tell them your age and
your occupation your interests
by giving them much less information
you've told them a lot more because
you're giving them a handle on
who you are at this emergent higher
level where we're human beings with
interest and occupations and things like
that right right so so the point though
is that newtonian mechanics doesn't
might i think the reason why i'm getting
confused is because newtonian mechanics
doesn't have a kind of fundamental
metaphysical status
if we have a theory of everything it's
not included in that theory it's
actually
derived from it in some sense right um
so similarly if if
if consciousness is as a kind of
metaphysical
part of the world the way in which
gravity and electromagnetism
and and these kinds of things are part
of the fundamental theory is
it's it's spooky and weird to say that
it just
arises later in the same sense that
newtonian
mechanics does because we're saying here
newtonian mechanics isn't fundamental
it's actually just
a derivable thing and consciousness
isn't a derivable thing
like from pattern phenomenal later it
seems to be more to be
like a core essential primitive thing
it's like primitive like you can't
it there's no way that it's not
primitive
no i think that there's a big way
there's not very much okay okay sure so
maybe that's
i think that's why there's this
confusion between say you and philip
gough
and people who take idealism and pan
psychism seriously
so yeah i mean and i i don't i don't
think it's a it's a
close call or a fair fight i mean i know
that i'm made of all these atoms and
they're all obeying the laws of physics
there's no room in there for anything
else
but they're but there are the
fundamental forces right
well the laws of physics what is the
laws of physics yeah
but then how why are you conscious
that's that's a an emergent pattern at
the higher level
why well the laws of physics allow for
that in the specific arrangement of the
physical world
uh instantiates it but it sounds like
you're just talking about the easy
problem and not the hard problem
i think the heart problem just
evaporates i think that there's not
going to be like
some some brilliant philosopher or
neuroscientist 20 years from now is
going to say
i've made a discovery and i now
understand the hard problem
i think as we understand more and more
about how the brain works
and how it gives rise to human beings
talking about and feeling their
experiences
it will just stop being interesting
sorry yeah that's uh
so sorry that's only funny because it's
very interesting to me
and i don't see it becoming not
interesting um
and so i mean i think wrapping up here
it seems that the difference is
so you think that the heart problem will
go away or become uninteresting
and then my position is more like it
seems primitive
and there's this sharp distinction
between the qualitative and quantitative
and the qualitative almost being an
innate capacity
at the beginning and where the
fundamental forces and this physicalism
is only describing the quantitative
and then i'm saying well there's this
capacity for this purely qualitative
thing like from the start
that seems primitive that i would like
to have included in the fundamental
metaphysics
and you're saying that um it's actually
an emergent phenomenon like newtonian
physics is a phenomenon it's part of our
folk
it's part of our folk ontology it's part
of our folk uh way of describing the
world it compresses a lot of information
that is very useful in the same way that
uh when we talk about free will
um it compresses information in a way
that is useful
um yet it's still it's it's
the hard problem is still compelling to
me um
and it doesn't it doesn't make it
doesn't make sense
so i guess you know a word on it i mean
just you know
i agree with everything you just said uh
just to point out
the idea that certain problems seem
incredibly pressing
and then don't get solved but kind of
evaporate away because our perspective
change and we realize they weren't that
pressing after all
happens all the time in science right
back in the days of kepler and
copernicus
why are there five other planets other
than the earth right you know mercury
venus mars jupiter saturn
that was an incredibly pressing question
and they came up with all sorts of
elaborate schemes to do it just a
hundred years ago
why is the fine structure constant one
over 137
arthur eddington you know worked very
very hard at understanding this
and now we know these are just not
interesting questions or you know it's
not exactly 137 there's not
five planets you know we change our
perspective on what questions are
important and what are not
wait okay but yeah so so
to use a bit of jargon that's like
nomological
right uh the
the the the brute facts of of physical
oh we have constants and so
i i mean so i actually think that those
are really good questions and i think
there are hard problems
of constants so like there's a hard
problem of of consciousness i think
there's a hard problem
of and so if you want like a full theory
then like
ultimate reality has chosen those
constants like why
yeah sure it's not it's not an exact
analogy but my point is just that
what might drive research and
intellectual inquiry forward in terms of
questions we're trying to answer
might change not because we answer the
questions but because our idea of what
is an important question might change
oh i see what you mean um
i see so in in kind of like a more
ethical or moral or pragmatic sense
well no i mean in terms of what is what
what is the what are the sets of
questions
that would give us true insight to
answer like if you told kepler
well the reasons why there's five other
planets is because we're one solar
system
there's many many different solar
systems that have different numbers of
planets
in fact there aren't just five planets
there's other planets you haven't seen
it's just an
accident of where we happen to be in the
world it's not something that is
fundamental in and of itself
uh he would not have considered that a
good answer to his question
you know but we now know that's the
right one
okay
um
so something feels uh i've really loved
this so far
some things and and something feels um
like unsatisfied you know like uh
like like you might feel unsatisfied
with
with how i view the hard problem as
being serious and
i feel unsatisfied in terms of you
kind of explaining it seems almost
anti-realist
uh well no i mean i actually i do get it
i tried in in the big picture to um i
see
put forward a dialogue between someone
who really took the hard problem
seriously and someone who didn't
um i i had david chalmers on the podcast
and you know i tried to press him on
this you know and
uh i said well you know a zombie would
think they're
conscious right you know by definition
that's what they would tell you and so
how do you know you are conscious how do
you know you're not a zombie and he's
like i just know that
i experience it it's part of who i am
what can i tell you
yeah and you hit a point where further
discussion is not going to be very
helpful
okay i think that's a good place to to
end there on that
um you do hit a place and i mean i i i'm
in the chambers camp i'm just like i
know
this is the thing that i know first i
take the the i take the descartes line
of view i'm like
this is more certain than the external
world and we're actually come
back to consciousness after assuming the
external world to make the kinds of
arguments that you make um
and and so the external world is
actually a kind of inference
whereas the reality of consciousness is
is more like prima
facie true um
[Music]
and yeah so it's it's
it's quite interesting and difficult
philosophical ground
and i am also aware of how it almost
feels like
ramming your head against a wall uh
when people are talking about this with
with different perspectives
yep i think that's completely right you
have nothing to disagree with out there
all right so i want to hit you with a i
want to hit you with a fun one here
um so this comes from the audience um
specifically someone from the qualia
research institute who
takes consciousness is is kind of
metaphysically fundamental
um yeah so
i've heard you say the on i think it was
on the joe rogan podcast you said
the good thing about the multiple worlds
interpretation is it doesn't really
change how you should live your life
now in the effective altruism community
and some
quite avant-garde philosophical thinking
there's a realm of infinite ethics
i'm not sure if you've heard of infinite
ethics it's about um
how utilitarians deal with the multiple
world interpretation of quantum
mechanics
and so the question from the audience
here is
is the number of moments of experience
larger in the future
due to the repeated bifurcation of the
universal wave function
should we care more about what happens
in the future
because there are more copies of it so
at the future of life institute we work
on trying to reduce and mitigate
existential risk
so does this sort of increase the
priority of existential risk by meaning
that the the future is more valuable
than the past
so i think the first thing i should say
is i'm not a utilitarian and thought
experiments like this are part of why
i'm not a utilitarian i think that
utilitarianism
makes seems like perfectly reasonable
when you when you first
face up to it but then when you think
about what it means it kind of falls
apart in a whole bunch of ways
having said that i think that even
utilitarians should not be
overly concerned with the wave function
of the universe
um or at least let me say the following
i think that as a meta-ethical principle
as i said before
i think that moral philosophy comes from
trying to systematize and make rational
and coherent
our intuitions so if you
have a view of what utilitarianism means
in the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics
and then you realize it completely
violates your intuitions
then i think that you have the right to
back up and fix your
utilitarian uh guess as to how to apply
that to many worlds so
if you were a super naive utilitarian
who counted utility by just adding up
the utility
in all branches of the wave function
right then
clearly the best way to be a good person
is just to duplicate the universe over
and over again right to go into your
basement
and make quantum measurements so you
make lots of different universes however
that's possible
and that literally affects
nobody in the world like no one's life
is changed by you
in your basement you know measuring a
bunch of spins of atoms and therefore
branching the wave function of the
universe so i would say
you need to back up and and and fix your
utilitarian calculus and the
obvious way to do it is to say that not
all universes are created equal
just as we assign a probability measure
to the outcomes of experiments in many
worlds we say that okay
if uh if a certain spin is square root
of two-thirds
spin up plus square root of one-thirds
spin down
what i'm going to say the words i'm
going to use are there's a two-thirds
probability i will observe spin up and a
one-third probability i observe spin
down
and a non evaredian would say that's
crazy pants
there is a hundred percent probability
that one version of you will see spin up
and one version of you will see spin
down
where does this two thirds and one third
come from and the answer is
everything in a sensible
ever-ready and many worlds view of the
world needs to be weighted
by the wave function squared that's the
thing that gives you probabilities that
the thing that adds to one
it's concern it's conserved over time
why doesn't it violate
energy conservation to make new worlds
because you need to multiply by the wave
function squared
so i would argue that the same exact
thing is true for utility if you're a
utilitarian i'm not a utilitarian but if
you want to be
a sensible non-crazy utilitarian in many
worlds
you have to count utility as being
proportional to the
thickness or the weight of the
individual worlds you can't just w
the utility the utility when you branch
the wave function of the universe
and in that case going into your
basement and splitting the wave function
of the universe by measuring a bunch of
spins
has exactly zero effect on the utility
of the universe and so that is why i
conclude that the right way to behave
in many worlds is exactly the same way
as you would behave whatever that
is if you thought that quantum
measurements were truly probabilistic
truly stochastic obeying the rule that
the probability is just the wave
function squared
sorry so maybe maybe i missed the part
of the argument here
um it so uh
i think i've heard you say that we're
unsure if
everything happens somewhere
or if just some very large fraction
happens
and well it's not that we're unsure
certain things will never happen
like things which are contradictory well
just things that contradict the
schrodinger equation
like uh you know charge will not be uh
charge conservation will not be violated
yeah okay i mean without getting too out
there i mean
that is true given our given this
universe like with from within
if there's a multiverse like for example
max has
a view that all possible mathematical
structures exist and so
that then if that were true then this
view would be incorrect
yeah good for him but i'm not talking
about that i'm just talking about the
predictions of the ever ready and many
worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics there is some schrodinger
equation
that evolves the wave function forward
and that does not imply that everything
happens it implies that the schrodinger
equation makes certain predictions for
what's going to happen
okay and so
[Music]
do you so so a utilitarian
so when you're when you're branching the
universe are you not
duplicating the value of the value or
this value that is here
you're not that's that's the crucial
point so
let's imagine that you were not a never
ready and let's imagine you thought that
quantum measurements were
truly random right we're truly
stochastic there's
if you measure a a spin that is in a
weight function
square root of two-thirds spin up square
root of two-thirds spin down and you
just do that over and over again there's
only one world we're imagining
but two-thirds of the time it'll be spin
up and one-third of the time it'll
be spin down okay so i would argue that
a sensible utilitarian
in that case what are they going to try
to maximize they'll maximize the
expectation value
of the utility right you know if you
think that spin up has a certain utility
and spin down has a certain utility
but you don't know because it's
stochastic you should try to maximize
the expected value of that utility
so my point is that you should do
exactly the same thing
in many worlds you don't just add the
utilities of different branches
you take their expectation value and you
weight them
by the square root of two-thirds by
two-thirds or one-third
i see i see
um and that leads to how you would
behave regardless of
of many worlds yeah sorry why is that
the expected value of utility is the
same whether or not the world is
fundamentally stochastic or whether or
not there are many worlds
it's you're calculating the same thing
there's no difference to what you would
predict okay
i see
um and and sorry why isn't that clear to
me is it because the negative
is it because of the how the math works
out um
i'm not sure why it's not clear but uh
the
you know when you if you say if you're
never ready and you say that okay i have
the spin
square root of two thirds spin up square
to two thirds spin down i swear to one
third spin down
and i measure it now i say okay now
there are two worlds
one in which it was spin up one in which
it was spin down yeah but
each world has an amplitude it's not
just that there are two worlds
one world is square root of two-thirds
times this world and the other world is
square root of one-third times that
world
and whether it's energy or
utility you should take the expected
value by
squaring those amplitudes and and
multiplying that by the value
in that world and then adding together
which is exactly what you do if the
world is fundamentally stochastic it's
the same
process so i see what you're saying yeah
i see um you're doing i okay i see
okay that makes sense now i i would i
wouldn't be able to say it back to you
uh i said yeah i i'm i'm mathematically
naive but it makes sense
um all right so i'm i'm mindful of the
time here and i would like to kind of do
a full circle here with you
of um of of
you know being a thoughtful
scientifically
and philosophically informed person in
the
21st century i mean one thing that i
really appreciate you
is how eclectic your um
how eclectic your your knowledge is
i think you you've mentioned how
sometimes physicists or cosmologists can
be philosophically naive
i mean i really appreciate that point
and um
the the the kind of uh depth and breadth
that you bring
to to to all fields of inquiry
from from ethics to to science to
philosophy
um so in the spirit of
of of having that kind of depth and
breadth which seems increasingly
important in the 21st century because
the world's only getting more
complicated and so it's demanding more
and more wisdom and knowledge from the
people which inhabit it
uh what would be your message and and
and suggestions and
and and and takeaways for for for humans
of the 21st century
um yeah that's hard to answer because
you know i have nothing
much more interesting to say than a
bunch of cliches um
yeah of course it's in important and
interesting to learn lots of different
things about lots of uh
different fields but i guess the
non-trivial thing i would say is
um be very cognizant
of i mean i guess let's put it this way
some version of the principle of charity
is what i would uh advise people to do
um
you know there was this uh famous slash
infamous example recently in the
pandemic
where tyler cowan who was a former
podcast guest also
um wrote a blog post he's an economist
and he wrote a blog post that was pretty
insulting towards epidemiologists
they're not as smart as we economists
are they have a lot to learn from us
right
and on the one hand maybe they do have a
lot to learn that's completely possible
to me
on the other hand it was not i think
that you could do a lot better job when
you when you enter a new field and by
the way physicists did the same thing
there's also famous examples of
physicists
saying well we'll we'll model
epidemiology in our spare time because
we're physicists it's easy for us
um taking the difficulties of other
fields
seriously is very very hard
and you know asking what questions why
they think the questions are important
that they do
why they've made the choices they made
etc it's very very hard because
it's not that different people coming
from different perspectives
don't have anything to offer i think
that physicists and epid and economists
and whoever
might have a lot to offer epidemiology
but the first
impulse should be to be humble to be to
say like
i'm new here explain to me what's going
on
let me learn rather than to come in and
say let me tell you how it is because
you know i have this superior training
and i can figure things out i think that
usually people from different fields
are not smarter than the people of the
fields that they're trying to learn
about and talk to
so by all means be intellectually
curious and wander into other fields
even make suggestions to them but be
reasonably humble while doing it that
would be my idea
so so you meant you meant epistemic
charity
yeah not like moral charity no that's
also important too but yeah i'm thinking
about
epistemic charity like try to think
about what other people are saying
in the best possible life that you can
imagine yeah
taking people on good faith i mean this
is also sam harris was on our podcast
and he talks about
uh how conversation is
so important i mean it's the only way
which we have to arrive at truth with
other people
and there's a sense in which taking
people on good faith
which is which is a kind of epistemic
charity is is sort of
essential and crucial to that process
which is but is you know deeply lacking
in
in our discourse um well it is but just
to make things harder
there are people who are not talking in
good shape so
i think that your first guess your first
move should be to take people in good
faith and try to see how far that goes
and at some point you can just shake
your head and go no sorry you're not
you're not playing along
yeah so and i guess just as a rapid fire
question here it's just coming up
to me uh before we close up um
sorry so in the in the philosophy of
mind do you have a
a formal position like if you were just
to say what it was like in terms of the
jargon what is it
um no i i don't trust my knowledge of
the dragon well enough to give anything
obviously i'm a physicalist
um i'm a compatibilist when it comes to
free will um
details about how the mind works i i uh
are above my pay grade sorry i meant
philosophy of consciousness
oh um well so i mean what what choices
you're going to give me differently
like idealism and pan psychism and
emergentism
yeah i'm a physical i'm a physicalist i
don't i am an emergentist in my own
vocabulary but i know that in other
people's minds that word means something
else so i don't call myself that uh
among philosophers
okay that still leaves me a little bit a
little bit confused because
these these these the views and this the
tradition of philosophy of mind
or philosophy of consciousness uh kind
of give different epidemic credences
right so idealism says
reality is ultimately made of
consciousness pancychism says that
there's fundamental physical stuff yet
it also has a mental property to it
along with the physical properties and
then emergentism says that like
you get all this stuff that comes
together and then like newtonian physics
kind of emerges from quantum physics
consciousness emerges from from
quantum physics or the interaction of
physical stuff
right but but and so i use the word
emergence a billion times in
in the big picture and like i said i
would describe myself that way
but there is a tradition of emergentism
which says that there are things that
exist at the emergent levels
which even in principle cannot
be traced down to a more fundamental
um view of the world so that that
principle
is is important to me so uh
and the the dichotomy that is set up is
sometimes reductionism versus
anti-reductionism
but i don't think that's the right
dichotomy
either so i'm actually writing a paper
that i call figurative
reductionism because i do think that
there are levels of description
that have different domains of
applicability and different amounts of
comprehensiveness when describing the
world
but i don't think that the more
comprehensive descriptions are
necessarily
descriptions of smaller pieces of nature
that
that fit into some uh naively
reductionistic
formula so it's a little bit more subtle
than that so
i the the only word that i'm a hundred
percent comfortable giving myself in
these uh discussions is physicalist
um okay that that's wonderful i mean i
so i've bashed my head against the wall
i think probably like
three to five times uh having people
explain to me why reductionism isn't
true
you just talked about how there are
emergent things which cannot be reduced
to
ultimate laws that to me i have i still
don't understand it and i'll
i'll need someone else to sit down with
me for five hours to explain
why that's true i keep having people
tell me that it's not true that
reductionism is not true
uh and that to me is is is is amazing
it might just be vague it might not be
your fault yeah
um all right and so as a very last
question
before i want to get your details about
about your podcast and where
uh my audience can follow you and check
you out and and your books
um do you do you also have then a
a sort of a formal uh meta-ethical view
you talk about how it's a systemization
of intuitions
um yet a lot of meta ethics you know
like for example
error theory says that all moral
statements are false and then there's
uh kind of moral realism which says some
are false and some are true
uh what is your perspective then on meta
ethics and
yeah there i do map on more cleanly to a
well-known
uh point of view which is humane
constructivism okay so i
not quite a relativist because
relativists will say that
morals are relative to you know some
society or culture or whatever
um but i'm not an objectivist or realist
either i don't think that morals are out
there to be discovered i think that we
construct them we make them
um and so the difference between human
human constructivism and kantian
constructivism
is the idea that there might be one
right way to construct them would be a
kantian point of view and a human point
of view is there might be more than one
way
that you could sensibly construct moral
truths
but the difference between a
constructivist and a relativist is that
a
constructivist has no trouble being
judgy of other people
once i construct my morals i can
absolutely judge other people
by my standards and i can i will try to
persuade them that my standards are good
ones and we'll see how far that goes but
there's no guarantee of success
right and there's no but there's no true
there's no true or false answer there's
no ultimately third person true or false
answers there's only like what has been
constructed given
that's right my framework so this is
then coherent within
this other kind of epistemological
framework you have of
the algorithmic compression of things
and so metaethics is just kind of an
algorithmic compression
or it leads to algorithmic compression
of of morality into some system which i
can then
apply from the folk the folk ontology
yeah you know i'll have some impressions
about things that i
feel intuitively are right or wrong but
i don't stop there i realize that well
you know i'm trying to
live according to some principles but i
haven't yet articulated what they are
and when i
do try to articulate what they are i
might realize that some of my initial
impulses were
wrong and i should i should fix them and
i can do that i can update on that basis
all right well hey thank you so much
sean this has been a lot of fun
uh it's definitely shifted a lot of my
opinions and
um yeah it's really a pleasure to talk
with you and have you here if people
want to check you out check out the
mindscape podcast
uh your new books follow you on twitter
uh where the best places
to do that the one stop shopping is my
website
preposterousuniverse.com so that's where
the podcast lives
mindscape podcast is available wherever
my wherever podcasts are available but
there's a webpage
uh on my site and you know twitter sean
m carroll is where i'm most active these
days i still have a blog but i don't use
it that much so
between twitter podcasts and the book
that's where you'll find most of my
words coming out
all right sean well uh thanks so much
all right thanks for having me lucas
take care